-Ashley, your family just made
a list of things at a gym.
-Hmm.
-Time to start guessing.
-Dumbbells.
-Whoo-hoo-hoo!
-Juice-heads.
-I'm so sorry, Ashley.
-[ Laughing ] Juice-heads.
-That's a brain freeze.
[ Alarm blaring ]
-Oh, come on!
Oh! Oh!
Oh, my gosh!
-[ Screams ]
-Oh!
How about when it goes
in your crack, huh?
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Kristen Bell
and Dax Shepard.
So, "Family Game Fight!" --
it's very fun,
because you have families
competing against each other,
but then, you guys
actually compete, as well,
which I think makes it
a lot more enjoyable to watch,
because this show -- and don't
take this the wrong way --
seems a little mean.
-Thank you so much.
-It's the meanest show there is.
-We hate this show.
-It's a bad, bad show.
-It's cruel. It's --
-It's rude.
-There's malice.
-What kind of show --
Because that "Brain Freeze" game
you just saw, it's not just ice
being dumped on your head.
They hook us up to a tube,
to the inside of our shirt.
So it goes --
Ice goes right on your skin.
That's why --
I mean, it's brutal!
There's pies to the face.
There was a trampoline game
when we came in,
and we're like,
"Wait, we're guessing clues,
but we have to be
jumping on the trampoline?"
And our producers
are like, "Yeah."
-And we both get nauseous
within two jumps.
-They go,
"Well, if you puke, you puke."
And we were like,
"What did we sign up for?"
But we didn't really
look at the games.
-Life's moving fast, Seth.
You just kind of wake up on set
and you learn
you're gonna have --
In that game,
we played six times in a row,
so 18 buckets of ice
on the head.
And --
-It's not cute. It's not nice.
-No. But --
-Do you think the families --
I'm sorry to interrupt,
but do you think the families
ever look at you
and think, "We know why
we're doing this,
but why are you doing this?"
-Sure.
-I think it's 50/50.
Yeah, it's polarizing.
There's like half
that would say that,
like, "You guys
really are silly."
-"You're really flushing
your careers down the toilet,
aren't you?"
-We heard a bit of --
The murmurs of that.
And then,
other people that are like,
"Oh, they're kind of cool
because they are not going to
win any money,
and here they are with us."
So, you know,
it can go either way.
-I also want to
ask about this before we go.
Kristen,
you have an animated show
that you are doing called
"Do, Re & Mi."
This is for younger kids.
This is maybe the kind of show
that my children could watch.
-This show could have kept you
safely indoors, Seth.
-That's true.
-Oh, thank God, yeah.
-So, yeah, two of my friends
and I got together.
They had this great idea.
As music and art was being
slashed from public schools --
And still is.
And that's been happening
for 20 years.
How music was so
formidable in my life.
It brought me here right now, if
I hadn't had a love for music.
It also proves, you know,
expanding their
brains in math and social.
We were like, "How do we get
a music education
into a kid's life?"
And Amazon made
this great show with us.
It's about three little
songbirds, Do, Re, and Mi,
and everything about
the show is entertainment,
but it's also secretly teaching
your kid music theory
about different types of music,
cultural music,
how to make music.
And we'll have "games"
that go along with it,
because the kids
love to play it.
But if they're on it,
they're actually learning
how to interact with music,
make their own music,
cooperation, all these good
things for brain development.
-It's subversive.
-It's very subversive.
-Subversive.
-And it's -- Yeah,
really, really proud of it.
-Dax, will you be
a voice on this show?
-I will not.
I will not do that, Seth.
-It's a singing show.
-It's to teach people
about harmony and notes,
all things I can't accomplish.
-Gotcha.
-But if we need a car-engine
noise, we will call you.
-Or like the singers want to
point at some guy like,
"Ah, he sounds terrible" --
that could be me.
-That's nice of you offering
a way to participate.
You guys, it is always so
lovely to see you.
Thank you for
being here in person.
It was a delight.
-Well, it's our pleasure.
We owed you at least this much.
-"Family Game Fight!"
airs on Wednesday at 9:00 p.m.
here on NBC,
and "Do, Re & Mi"
will be on Amazon Prime Video
and Amazon Kids+
on September 17th.